so I am obsessed with horror movies and
I love the idea that this is going to be
the first for many young moviegoers out
there so I want to know what was your
first not necessarily the movie that
terrified you first but rather the first
one that you know made you in awe of the
thrill that you can experience in the
safety of a theater oh
I think the Lion King for me yeah
that was amazing
uh yeah this is grandiose ex like
experience with music and all these
Larger than Life characters
um that I felt like you know uh just
Africa as the backdrop of like being
seen young and I think the the main
actor the child actor
being black I could hear blackness in
his voice and it made me feel connected
to it and uh made me feel like uh I was
being seen on a large stage and perhaps
my family was too and so that was really
special and it was just like a lot of
love in it and um and I felt like I
related to so many of the themes in the
movies oh yeah that was a special one
the first horror movie first horror
movie still a beautiful answer oh oh is
that the question
I guess there's some scary scenes in
Lion King it is
[Laughter]
I don't know I think um probably I
didn't start watching those two a little
bit later but um I think maybe uh
Exorcist was the first one so I didn't
see it really in the theater but
um that one was one that stuck with me
for a long time I love that because in
Exorcist I was like I could walk like
that like I was like I grew up in the
lower the Lower Side of Manhattan I'm
from Coney Island too so it was like the
tattooed person and like bearded lady
and then I get to the Lower East Side
it's like tattoo faced people with like
tons of piercings everywhere and like
just people being unusual and like not
the normal kinds of personalities you
always see on screen except for when I
would watch these sort of like horror
kind of showy more campy kinds of
stories so I always really loved them
there was something so kind of
fascinating to me about them and like
those themes that were more intense
especially as a young person like
feeling like I was not being babied you
know and so I I appreciated that these
and you know even though it's you're not
supposed to talk about death or any of
these different kinds of things that's
the kind of stuff so in Poltergeist and
The Exorcist and I remember going to see
I think the first movie like I I went we
I went with like a
my friends we had roommates when we were
living in San Francisco I was 10 years
old 11 and we went to go see
arachnophobia
movies it's a great example oh I mean
like and then you know and I'll never
forget watching The Omen and feeling
like I finally understood my brother he
clearly was the Antichrist and being
really upset that he didn't have 666 and
the back of his head because I had
thought it explained so much so yes I
really and legends I remember watching
Legends as a kid and seeing Tim Curry
Barrel chested and hoped and like horned
and all this stuff and then it was like
sparkly Tom Cruise and I was like so I
love me a unicorn but kill the Unicorn
because Legend is where it's at the
sparkly dude like no like I remember
being like I'm not like other girls
this is a great list you just ratted off
there I love it I love the idea that
this could be a horror starter for a lot
of kids out there I'm excited about that
idea yeah it's a proper one I also love
talking about the value of a good scene
partner and you're both surrounded by
them in this movie so can you each give
me an example of a Time on the Haunted
Mansion set when a scene partner gave
you just what you needed and it helped
you reach something in your own
performance that you wouldn't have been
able to without them Danny in the uh
scene where we're trying to figure out
who had or we're trying to describe the
Hat Box goes to a sketch artist uh Dan
is just sitting next to me and um you
know generally I'm performing this way
because I'm talking to the person who's
right in front of me I might glancing
him every now and but general area of my
performance is this way and Danny's
sitting here and at one point I look
over at it and
his lip is just curled all the way back
over his teeth and it was the funniest
thing I'd ever seen and I'm trying so
hard not to laugh it was the hardest
thing I'd ever had to do and as soon as
they said cut I just started rolling and
I'm like on the floor like this dude is
hilarious what is happening on the side
of me that I'm missing because I'm going
this way so when we would go to
subsequent uh
um shots I would make sure I look over
there more often so I wouldn't be as
surprised by the ridiculous things that
he's doing but that are just so amazing
such a pro so I felt like really
grateful to to be honest anyway it's a
great example of a scene that plays
really well in the trailer and it
doesn't get ruined by the trailer it
still is just as funny in the full
feature yeah I love it for sure
um
I don't know I mean I was just
constantly blown away I have to say
probably one of my favorite scenes to do
was Tiffany Tiffany and I showing up for
Jamie doing her coverage so we had done
all of us and you know this ball and the
camera's on us so it's okay and you know
script supervisors reading the lines but
then when we turned it around I'm there
Jamie Lee Curtis who I absolutely adore
so much and she's there with little dots
on her face and you know she's just
repeating this monologue of stuff that
she's got to say brilliantly every time
the different textures and voices and
experimenting and seeing like where we
were gonna land with Madame Leota and
it's me and Tiffany like trying to act
out all of us so I'm like we're doing
this scene and like and then I'm jumping
down to Danny and trying to giving her
our eye line for Danny being like three
dollars that's highway robbery and then
coming back up for our lines and doing
whatever and it was just one of the
funnest times me and Tiffany just being
absolutely delighted clearly working
with this icon that we are are so
obsessed with and just having so much
fun and like being amazed that we were
being paid to do that
experience for sure
I believe that they happen have either
of you experience a ghost wink and if so
what was it a ghost wink yeah like where
like like tater tot yeah or the uh the
train yeah for sure yeah yes yeah these
signs these Omens in your life that you
come across that are you know I'm really
like uh interested in numerology and
dates and like you know astrology you
know a lot how the planets line up and
I'll find on like certain dates certain
things happen that initiate things in my
life that are really profound in one way
or another and they seem to be linked to
like these people that I've known in my
past who are no longer here and I I
sometimes try to speak to them just to
see if that's the case and I'm always
getting an answer in one way or another
so
it's it's interesting to think about
yeah it's I've definitely seen some
ghost links before